as the rain comes down the neighborhood
of Maple Creek is in sheer panic tonight
as I stand right outside of the house of
entrepreneur Gary Goldwater less than an
hour ago police and firefighters were
called to the home after several reports
of gunfire were heard coming from inside
the house of the young millionaire
when police arrived they found the house
swallowed up in flames
I'm live on location I'm Malcolm Network
Carrie
Carrie
April
oh [ __ ]
whoa [ __ ] you killed her man oh [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] moving oh
you're we were doing here oh my god okay
you're fine you're fine
oh oh [ __ ] missiles that was loud
that's fast huh what what hey come on
you're off my right nipple yes I don't
feel it man what the hell did you do
that for
so talking about remember we agreed we'd
assess the situation before busting into
your bullets the balls get what I
assessed
there was no assess it was assessed
really yeah cuz I could have sworn I
heard him say Slater [ __ ] who's that
man we even in the right house we're not
in the wrong house I can tell you that I
mean I checked like three times I
thought about a fourth but I stopped
myself because I knew up you're in the
right house oh my [ __ ] oh my [ __ ] dude
dude this it's nothing like the picture
way to go Jim like what the [ __ ] man
okay you might have got beautiful
reconstructive surgery or were in the
wrong house and he's gonna kill us
where did it oh we're so gay how do you
think this habit well Tim we walked into
the room and you shot the wrong [ __ ]
guy that's how this happened
I'm talking about the chick and I don't
know I was really starting to freak out
here yeah yeah yeah me too
really Ken because you seemed quite
peaceful for a time like this
Thanks I'm taking glasses you should
come with next week come with I think
I'm gonna be sick sick
hey listen I got a fat stack of tones
I'm talking okay you want one all right
come here what are you doing what do you
mean what am i doing I'm giving you the
hinds maneuver so what sometimes
maneuver you mean the Heimlich maneuver
Greg yeah you're right yeah well Heinz
is a condiment and the highlight
maneuvers for people who are choking I'm
neither
it seems I'm an error okay this Christ
you want to know something I'm not gonna
shoot this guy we're supposed to be here
we shouldn't [ __ ] be here
don't even look at me like that I google
bet the crap out of that man
18:16 Park would drive anyone's to blame
it's Google really yeah it's 16 park
would drive no deaf-mute where you go
Tim yes so road man 816 Park would
[ __ ] roll crap
sometime in error yes you are [ __ ]
air hey hey hey worth it everything okay
you saw I wanna sort out what he's doing
what you're supposed to shoot her why
cuz she's been sitting here for the past
10 minutes listening in every word we
said including our names okay all right
you know you get mad at me for shooting
too quick and now we can't even just
help this young lady get a soda maybe a
Jamba Juice you a Jamba Juice huh if
it's him
oh we just burned someone we're not
murderers or hitmen or maybe like thrift
store James Bond's we're only hitmen if
you hit the right target right now we're
[ __ ] murderers and murderers can't
help people she's just an innocent girl
that wants some soda
enough with the so not all right all
right I'll get our Jamba Juice oh [ __ ]
jumbo juice its Jamba enough with the
Vic weeds look if we don't kill her
she's going to be able to identify us
well not me I have a mask antigens
pretty thirsty and I read she knows
what's going on like that do you know
what's going on right now I don't think
anyone involved in this situation has
any idea what the [ __ ] is going on you
know if you're so torched up about it
why aren't you to it well fine the hell
are you doing are you doing the gun give
me the gun where is your gun
trip yeah man that's all in my soda ah
ah have to clean this up what heat it up
why looking any evidence oh man I need a
major rest bit crispy you have a respite
what are you doing with heat weight or
other problems
alright I'm gonna clean this up so fresh
so fresh and so clean clean so as you
take off so sexy oh just so fresh so
clean Oh
it's bit loud
what's up man
we'll just make it worse a good blood
Traxxas that is leaving gonna be here
all night clean it up this [ __ ] calm
down
alright we're like 5/16 there we've got
the business guy in the trunk Oh God
5:16 ok estimation Tim we still have to
figure out a way to get rid of these
bodies after we get him into the car and
then we have to find out a way erasing
any trace of us being here for the past
hour 5/16 my ass dude alright good total
junk out you need to go we need a bar
that come out man I'm trying ok
sometimes it's just a little picky gotta
get this set
[ __ ] it
police and firefighters who were here on
location were called to the home after
several fruit Forks have gun I was
[ __ ] my mouth [ __ ] my mouth
I'm sorry I know alive the rain is
coming down here in the neighborhood of
maple creek and it is [ __ ] police and
firefighters who are right here to my
right causing a ruckus what's up to the
home of the ones W
one two three
you
you